I think everybody knows by now this is a
very remote site it's 1500 miles to the
east of the United States the East Coast
it's about 350 miles south of St John's
in Newfoundland and of course the
Titanic lies at a depth of nearly 4 000
meters
apart from going into space you couldn't
get in a much more remote site
the problems you have is that you have a
tiny vehicle it's only about 21 feet
long it's on the bottom somewhere it's
amongst the debris of Titanic itself the
seabed is undulating
the Titanic wreck itself lies in a
canyon so actually finding this is going
to be really difficult a bit like a
needle in a haystack
and and in terms of the immediate fear
Chris is is it running out of oxygen
from what we've heard it's got about
four days worth of oxygen so they they
said 96 hours my my concern is that the
the safety Beacon that transmits every
20 minutes gave up I think after an hour
and 45 minutes into the dive that's
suggestive of itself there's no
emergency Beacon whatsoever been sort of
heard at all so finding this thing is
going to be really difficult
I'm normally optimistic but I have to
tell you in these circumstances it's
very worrying indeed
if a rescue was to be made what are we
talking about getting another
submersible down near where they are and
transferring the people out or would you
have to bring uh the Titan back back to
the surface somehow what what would be
the the process to rescue the five
passengers it's a really good question
we're in unknown territory here
um you can't possibly put another uh
vehicle over the top of it and get the
people out at that depth uh the The
Vessel has to be brought to the surface
and the only two options You've Really
Got are essentially putting a Hauser
down to it and putting it around the
thing and dragging it to the surface
with a crane and one of the rescue craft
I see has got a crane like that but the
difficulties of putting a wire down that
far uh we're talking about miles here
and then actually dragging the thing up
a pretty remote the only other option is
to deploy a similar submersible which
has grabbing arms that you can put on
the on the front of it and then if you
like just hug the stricken vessel and
bring it to the surface in a sort of
piggyback fashion but I must emphasize
uh these uh these these vessels are
essentially kit cars they're not normal
submarines they're built uh in an
experimental way and this particular one
is uh shall we say built from components
that you can get off the internet from
Amazon so they're very flimsy they're
very fragile and you can't allow a lot
to go wrong before you're in danger well
I guess that raises um separate
questions at how these excursions were
allowed to to take place at Great costs
as well according to reports but that's
perhaps a debate for another day
also just wondering uh whether there's a
chance that this is on the surface I I
read one report in fact it wasn't a very
hopeful report
um suggesting that if it had come up to
the surface it wouldn't have been by
choice and perhaps could have happened
too fast but uh I guess it's just as
hard looking on the ocean floor to try
and find this as it would be if it were
somewhere on the surface or do we know
that it's not well I think if it were on
the surface it would have been found by
now there's been a maritime Patrol
aircraft very sophisticated
Air Force aircraft looking for any sign
of this now the sort of sensors they've
got can pick up uh sort of rubber
dinghies and things like that so had it
come to the surface within about even up
to sort of 50 miles of the site it would
have been found by now I would have
suspected and you're absolutely right
the only way that people could have
survived an initial problem is if they'd
drop their their weights which they have
on the side of the thing and use their
compressed air to get to the surface I
haven't seen any evidence that that has
happened and I think the odds are that
the vessel is still at depth and either
needs rescuing or I'm afraid to say has
reached a sticky end